والغرب مصدر وتهديدات وجوديه هذا قليل من
كثير في وثيقه من 42 الصفحه للعقيده
الجديده لسياسه الخارجيه الروسيه اعتمدها
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين بتوقيع مرسوم خاص
وبخطاب محمد برسائله لخصومه النسخه
المحدثه لسياسه موسكو مع الخارج ولدت في
سياق حرب تصفها بالهجينه واعاده توزيع
التحالفات المعلنه منها والمستتره عن
الخطوط العريضه للرؤيه الجديده وملامحها
واهدافها اصاب وزير الخارجيه الروسي في
الحديث
في العقيده تتوفر امكانيه اتخاذ اجراءات
متناسقه او غير متناسقه ردا على اي خطوات
عدائيه موجهه ضد روسيا في المفهوم الجديد
للسياسه الخارجيه الروسيه تم تحديد
الولايات المتحده بشكل مباشر كمبادر رئيسي
وقائد للخط المعادي لروسي في العالم وهو
يلقي الضوء على احدى اولويات روسيا التي
تتمثل في ازاله بقايا هيمنه الولايات
المتحده والدول غير الصديقه على الشهور
الدوليه
ومن البنود الاخرى المهمه في السياسه
الجديده وليدتي اجواء تذكر بزمن الحرب
البارده نجد ان روسيا ستسهم في تقليص فرص
البلدان غير الصديقه في اساءه استخدام
مركزها للتاثير في الاقتصاد العالمي ستسعى
موسكو جاهده الى اقامه نظام عالمي يوفر
الامن الموثوق به والفرص المتساويه للجميع
ستستخدم القوات المسلحه لصد ومنع هجوم
مسلح عليها او على حلفائها تتطلع موسكو
بشكل خاص الى تعميق العلاقات والتنسيق
الشامل مع مركزي القوه الصديقين الصين
والهند
على الشرق فتحت الابواب على مصراعيها منذ
مده التقارب بين موسكو وبيجين يزيد ويتوسع
امام اعين الغاضبين والمنتقدين له هذا
التحالف يقابله تحالف غربي يغدق المال
والسلاح على اوكرانيا في حرب كل تفاصيلها
ومنذ البدايه تقول انها بالوكاله محاولات
الغرب عزل روسيا وتعظيم مخاطر تهديدات
التنين الصيني اتت بمفعول غير محبب
لخصومهما قربت بين القوتين رغم خلافاتهما
المتوارثه وتصادم مصالحهما في بعض مناطق
النفوذ ومن وثيقه العقيده الجديده
للخارجيه الروسيه نقرا ان العالم مقبل على
تحالفات وتوازنات وصفقات مغايره تفرضها
حرب حدودها ما بعد اوكرانيا بكثير